[Music]
property brothers star drew Scott and
his longtime love Linda fan are married
I knew the moment I saw this lady I mean
look at her
the two met in 2010 and in 2012 she
began working with Scott brothers
entertainment she's the boss
the production team drew shares with his
twin brother Jonathan Scott oh she's
great Linda that's why she's a creative
director with our company - she has
brilliant ideas she has great aesthetic
and she she's really our property sister
we didn't say four years later in
December 2016 the HGTV star popped the
question any other song marry me by
train of course so I recorded that song
in studio and the whole plan was in the
restaurant when it comes to dessert I
wanted that to play off she's also a dr.
Seuss freak so I made that as a big cake
and on the top of the dr. Seuss
character holding the ring that song
played but he was with the couple just
weeks before they said I do tell me
about the wedding of your dreams
this groomzilla groomzilla he's quite
everything well I mean team effort
team effort I would say I mean Linda is
so creative and we have some fun ideas
the main thing is we want entertain
family and friends for the whole week my
tuxedo is actually gonna be a Scottish
tuxedo which means a kilt and I'll be
wearing it the traditional way
wait yeah